[Music]
to our cooking confidence coach is bag
Nanny Bubby she is here in studio thanks
to Chapman Automotive the sponsors of
the segment now today we're learning
some tips on intuitive cooking I love
that by Salt Fat acid Heat this is a
great this is what inspires the stuff
yes it is and if you don't know about
Salt Fat and acid how can you cook
intuitively because you don't know what
you're looking for right so I'll be
about just that's what you're tasting so
let's talk about salt okay salt is the
great enhancer and if you don't believe
me think about chicken soup without salt
in it tastes like dirty dishwater you
just don't want to do that here's pasta
same tastes like rubber so this is a
piece of pasta two tablespoons of salt
in the water I kind of like it plain
okay I understand taste this this has a
fistful of salt in the water it's very
salty right maybe a little too salty but
then we're going to add the acid to it
so right here we have the tomato sauce a
little bit of acid right over the top
there we go a little bit more for you
then we're going to add delicious add
the fat which is the parmesan cheese
which is also adds a little bit of salt
and it is acid now taste that same pasta
that was just slightly taste what about
someone who you know salt can also be a
little dangerous what about people okay
here's the thing right always use kosher
salt kosher salt is a thing to cook with
do not use iodized salt it came about
during the Great Depression we are not
there anymore so here's the deal if you
are cooking breakfast out of a
restaurant yeah there you go there you
go if you are cooking for yourself
you're always going to get less sodium
than if you eat in a restaurant kosher
salt has 53 percent less sodium and if
you're eating out of a bag call 9-1-1
because you've got more sodium than they
could use an entire week all right let's
talk about fat there are three purposes
of fat okay okay here is the first one
as a cooking medium so you put butter in
the pan you cook your eggs that's
cooking medium okay okay olive oil
sauteing vegetables number two as the
main ingredient think about ice cream
ice cream main ingredient is fat think
about hamburger why do we love Hamburger
because it is more fat than anything
else we eat for beef and lastly as a
seasoning so here we go taste this
croissant oh I have to eat a croissant
yes butter butter croissants okay gotta
eat fast okay and here it is with butter
I got to take you to this here's
asparagus real quickly taste this this
piece of asparagus nothing on it but
salt and pepper okay we're talking about
acid acid is the great brightener to
everything we're going to throw a little
bit of lemon juice on this with some
smoked sea salt and just a little bit
different there you go and a little bit
okay taste taste taste we got like again
all right there you go Salt Fat acid for
intuitive
it's the acid wow okay now I want to put
this over here and have a whole meal
thank you so much Nanny buffing and
Katie's Kitchen and Garden on social
media and online at nannybubby.com also
we want to again thank Chapman
Automotive for sponsoring this segment
there you go